근데 콘텐츠 뭐 하실 거죠?
>> 일단은 지금 급조하긴 했는데
>> 저희 10주년이니까 한번 창기해 보는
거 같아요.
>> 어
[웃음]
16년도에 만들어 가지고 벌써
[음악] 이제 10년이 됐네요.
>> 2017년 1월 1일이 상륙
기념이죠.
>> 그 이제 그때가 이제 법인 설립
1위고 개인 사업자는 16년도에
[음악] 때 이제 설립을 했었죠. 그
전에도 계속 공인 중에서 하셨던
거예요.
>> 자격증을 이제 2009년도에 땄다가
군대 갔다 오고 바로 이제 일 한
다음에 2016년도에 창업을 했죠.
>> 2009년도에다
[웃음]
미성년자요.
>> 그죠? 미성년자였죠. 그 원래는 이제
미성년장 시험 못 봤다가 그게 이제
[음악] 딱 폐지되는 시점이었어요.
내 아직도 기억에 남는게 전국에서
그때 몇백 명이 시험을 [음악]
치렀는데 10대가 근데 거기서
17명이 붙었는데 그중에 한 명이
접니다. 되게 이런 나이 땄죠.
>> 그 나이에 보통 공인분계사를 따고
싶어 하는 친구는 없잖아요.
>> 그죠? 그래서 자격증을
많은 분들이 되게 다 이제 어르신들이
딴다 [음악] 아니면 복덕빠 아저씨가
딴다라는 그런 뭔가 인식이 되게
심했는데 심지어 학교 선생님도 되게
무시했었거든요. 어 네가 그 자격증
어떻게 따냐 [음악] 앞에 불러
가지고 내가 얘 공인 중계에서 자격증
딴다라고 막 하는데 막 친구들도
웃기도 하고 선생님이 되게 무시 많이
했죠. [음악] 예. 근데 그게
오히려 더 동기 부여가 됐던 거
같아요. 열 받아서 내가 보여
준다라고 해가지고 주말에는 17시간씩
공부했었던 거 같아요. 아직도
생각나는게 자격증 따 가지고
선생님한테 [음악] 이렇게 보여줬던
통쾌했던 그런 기억도 있습니다.
>> 선생님 어떤 반응이셨어요?
>> 네가 진짜 딸 줄 몰랐다. [웃음]
>> 인정해 주신 거 같아?
>> 아 인정했죠. 예
>> 군대 갔다 오시서 출을 뛰신 거예요.
>> 그렇죠. 그래서 군대도 사실 영장이
안 나왔는데 빨리 군대를 가야겠다는
생각으로 이제 막 지원해서 갔죠.
경쟁률 제일 낮은 대로.
>> 저녁하고 나면 보통 친구들이 다 놀고
싶어 하잖아. 안 놀았고 저녁한 다음
날부터 일했어요. [음악] 근데
저녁하고 바로 다음날 이제 취업을 해
가지고 그때부터 지금까지 계속 일하고
있습니다.
>> 처음에 공중계서 하시면서 좀
무시했거나 그러셨던 배운
>> 처음에는 나이 어려서 잘 못 할
거다. 그리고 제가 뭐 술을 못
먹어서 술 못 먹으면 영어 못 한다.
그리고 이제 제가 되게 외형적인
성격은 아니거든요. 그러다 보니까
많은 사람들이 뭐 무시도 많이 하고
막 그랬는데 실제로 제가 만나서
영업하다 보니까 나이는 크게 중요하지
않더라고요. 오히려 더 좋게 보시고
오히려 더 아들 같다. 손자 같다.
그리고 오히려 더 뭔가 진정성이
있다. 사인 안칠 것 같다. 뭐 이런
얘기도 해 주시고 오히려 나이 어린게
더 무기였던 거 같아요. 근데 그런
건 있었죠. 초반에는 고정급이 사실
없잖아요. 대부분 다 성과고. 그래서
친구들이 되게 많이 무시했었던 거
같아요. 편의점 알바보다 내가 더 못
본다. 뭐 이런 식으로 되게 무시도
많이 했는데 지금은 뭐 너무 달라져서
[웃음]
그리고 무엇보다 이제 그때 당시에는
[음악] 집이 되게 안 좋았거든요.
집에서 돈 버는 사람 저밖에 없었고
아버지가 택시 운전을 하셨었는데 그때
이제 암에 걸리셔 가지고 [음악]
내가 빨리 돈을 벌어야 된 그런
상황이었습니다. 뭔가이 가정을 내가
살려야겠다라는 그런 책임감이 되게
컸던 거 같습니다. [음악]
그때 아버지랑 되게 많이 싸웠어요.
막 제가 이렇게 월 버는 돈이
없으니까 그만둬라. 진짜 심지어는
[음악] 그만두고 어디 막 중식당에서
일해라 뭐 이런 얘기도 했었고 되게
많이 싸웠던 거 같습니다. 물론
지금은 너무 좋아하시죠. 그리고
처음에 창업했을 때도 다 맞물려
있거든요. 어린 시절에 제가
주유소에서 5년을 일했어요. 한
주유소에서. 그래서 주유소에서
알바생으로 들어가서 어떻게 보면
서비스업을 배운 거거든요. 뭐 인사도
[음악] 하고 뭐 고객 상대하는 것도
배우고. 그래서 그게 지금까지
이어져서 창업하고 난 다음에도 되게
도움이 많이 [음악] 됐던 거
같아요. 영업하면서도. 그래서 되게
감사한게 어렸을 적에 제가 그렇게
만약에 부유한 가정에서 태어났다라고
하면 이렇게까지 아마 안 됐을 것
같습니다. 어떻게 뭐 가난했기 때문에
더 이상 떨어진 밑이 없거든요. 어
그게 원동력이 됐죠. 학비랑 급식비도
제가 냈거든요. 근데 그게 원래 이제
나라에서 지원이 [음악] 되는데 전
아직도 기억에 남는게 그때 이제
선생님이 학비 지원받을 사람비
지원받으 손 들려 그래요. [음악]
근데 그 진짜 어떻게 진짜 충격적인
거거든요. 그거 이제 손 들어서 이제
나가잖아요. 그럼 애들 이제 다
쳐다보고 되게 나만 이제비 지원받고
뭐 이런 얘기하 좀 그냥 쪽
팔리잖아요. 상처를 되게 많이
받았어요. [음악] 그때 어 그래서
내가 아 뭔가 내가 그냥 차라리 돈
벌어서 내가 내야겠다라는 생각을
가지고 그래서 제가 학비랑 급식비를
[음악] 제가 냈던 거 같습니다.
>> 공인중사 취득하게 되시고 회사에서
일하시다가 회사를 차리게 되셨잖아요.
그 계기가 뭐였어요? 제가 취업하고
난 다음에 그 중계사로 [음악] 계속
일하고 있었는데 제가 뭐 앞서
설명드렸던 것처럼 저는 창업을 되게
꿈꿔 왔던 사람이었고 [음악] 근데
아무래도 회사에 소속돼 있다 보니까
제약들이 되게 꽤 있긴 했었죠.
그래서 아 내가 뭔가 나은 대로 한번
해 봐야겠다라고 마음을 먹고 그때
[음악] 이제 결심을 하고 25살에
이제 어 창업을 하게 됐습니다.
보증금 5,000에 월세 70만
원짜리 주택에서 [음악]
시작했거든요. 주택 아마 여기 사진
띄어 드릴 거 같은데 진짜 없기
시작했어요. 주택에서 진짜
초라하거든요. 그게 많은 사람들이 막
지금 모습만 보면은 막 되게 우장한
데서 처음에 창업하고 막 돈도 많아
가지고 막 뭐 한 거 같고 막 이렇게
얘기하시는 분들이 꽤 [음악] 많은데
뭐 신입 파트너분들도 제가 항상 이거
보여 주거든요.이 창업했을 때 제
책상을 그거 보고 되게 놀라기도
합니다.
>> 옛날에 창업하실 때는 거의 혼자서
창업을 하셨는데 지금 파트너분이 어느
정도 되시죠? [콧방귀]
지금은 [음악] 중계 업체만 한
100명 가까이 되고 그다음에 뭐
설계사 사무서랑 [음악] 시공사도
있고 계열사도 몇 개 좀 이렇게
있습니다. 예. 물론 제가 [음악]
보니까 이게 물론 이제 혼자 다 할
수 없고 주변에 이렇게 괜찮은 분들이
많아서 지금 이렇게까지 된 거고
이렇게 좋은 사람들이 오려면 내가
좋은 사람이어야 되는 거고 그리고
내가 존경해야지 그들도 [음악]
뭐 나를 존경하는 거고 이게 맞아
떨어져야지 이렇게 좋은 사람들이 있는
거지 뭐 나만 잘났다고 뭐 내가 뭐
했다고 뭐 이렇게 해 가지고는 뭐
좋은 사람들이 안 오는 거
같더라고요. 근데 진짜 운 좋게 뭐
이렇게 좋은 사람들이 많이 모여
있어서 지금까지 이렇게 뭐 빠른
성장을 하지 않았나 이렇게 생각을
합니다.
>> 년 전에 사장님 저는 창업을
[콧방귀] 꿈꾸는 청년들에게 한 마디
부탁드립니다.
>> 그래서 그런 거 같아. 그러니까 막
사업이라는게 제가 봤을 때는 100%
성공하는 경우는 없어요. [음악]
대부분 일단은 시작하는게 되게 중요한
거고 내가 생각했던 부분이 아닐 수도
있어요. [음악] 막 갑자기 이슈가
발생될 수도 있고 그리고 항상 수정
보완을 하면서 헤쳐 나가는 [음악]
거기 때문에 만약에 뭐 창업을 고민
중이시다라고 하면은 일단은 시작부터
하시고 그리고 준비가 완벽히 된
상태에서 할 수는 없거든요. 그러면은
창업을 못 해요.
그래서 일단 [음악]
어느 정도 가닥만 잡고 시작한 다음에
계속 수정 보완한 다음에 하면은
[음악] 이제 그러면서 성장하는 거
같습니다. 100% 계획대로 되진
않아요. 창업 스토리는 1편은 이렇게
하고 이게 만약 반응 괜찮다 그러면
계속 [음악] 제가 어 후속편을 찍을
예정이니까 댓글 남겨 주시면 제가
다음 편도 한번 찍어 보도록
하겠습니다. 끝. M.